madame la ministre en guadeloupe en
martinique et en guyane le journal
france antilles ou france-guyane
appartient à un groupe de presse en
cessation de paiement l'unique quotidien
régional sera bientôt peut-être dans un
mois et demi en liquidation ces
territoires doivent pouvoir conserver
une place vivante et pluraliste une
peste qui a contribué au développement
de la citoyenneté de la liberté
d'opinion et de la démocratie dans nos
villes les mutations technologiques des
réseaux sociaux les changements dans les
habitudes de consommation met cependant
cause la survie de ce journal sa
disparition signifierait la perte
cumulée de 253 emplois à haut niveau de
qualification en guadeloupe en
martinique et en guyane
ces emplois sont occupés en grande
partie par des originaires leur niveau
de spécialisation rendra à la leur
démarche difficile voire impossible en
cas de liquidation
ce quotidien est aujourd'hui
constitutifs du patrimoine de ces
territoires
depuis plus de cinquante trois ans ils
rythment notre vie quotidienne
il doit être à ce titre préserver c'est
pourquoi il est nécessaire de mobiliser
l'ensemble des aides au pluralisme de la
presse périodique régionale le conseil
constitutionnel et le conseil d'état en
consacrer dans leur jurisprudence
la valeur constitutionnelle du
pluralisme de la presse écrite
ils ont également admis que soutiens
publics accrus devaient être apportées à
la presse d'information politique et
générale
je vous prie madame la ministre de nous
faire connaître les mesures que le
gouvernement entend prendre pour
maintenir une presse quotidienne
régionale vivante ainsi que les nombreux
emplois si importants ou des territoires
touchés par un chômage de masse qui en
dépendent la parole est à madame la
ministre d outre-mer la parole madame la
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur théophile oui malheureusement
vous avez raison la presse écrite
quotidienne en outre mer connaît
malheureusement des difficultés aux
antilles bien sûr mais aussi en guyane
et
à l'île de la réunion et ça nous impose
à tous de re penser ensemble de choses
d'abord le modèle économique de ce
secteur et ensuite de renouveler l'offre
l'offre aux lecteurs dans les pratiques
évoluent nous le savons tous et cette
question d'adaptation est nécessaire
aussi dans les territoires d'outre-mer
le groupe france antilles c'est
l'éditeur du premier quotidien de presse
en guadeloupe en martinique et en guyane
concrètement ce sens 285 salariés
répartis entre ces trois territoires et
pour la réunion c'est environ le même
nombre pour deux quotidiens le groupe
france antilles a été placé en
redressement judiciaire le 25 juin et le
tribunal de commerce de fort de france
se prononcera fin novembre des offres de
reprise sont d'ores et déjà déposé
le gouvernement est bien entendu
mobilisées depuis quelques mois sur ce
sujet a pris trois décisions
la première c'est une inspection iga
jack doit qui doit formuler des
propositions avant la fin de l'année sur
un soutien que nous devons apporter à
ces sectes à ce secteur
deuxièmement des outils pour faciliter
la trésorerie et là nous avons décidé de
pouvoir effectivement échelonnées dans
le temps les dettes sociales et fiscales
pour certains de ces organismes et puis
troisièmement je le dis je les demande
est défendue au siom au comité
interministériel à l'outre-mer
il faut que le comité interministériel
de restructuration industrielle ce qu'on
appelle le ciri qui a pour mission
d'aider les entreprises en difficulté
avec des solutions défini entre
actionnaires et créanciers puissent agir
sur ce sujet le premier ministre l'a
acté et validé c'est aujourd'hui chose
faite c'est trois engagements seront
tondues te seront tenus et puis vous
dire effectivement comme vous l'avez dit
en conclusion le dynamisme d'une presse
régionale est fondamental dans nos
territoires d'outre-mer comme partout
c'est le droit à l'information c'est
bien sûr aussi la vie démocratique qui
nous faut défendre